this makes more sense to me so i'm just
going to go with it right people are
just don't make dollars don't make sense
to the industry my boy they don't sign
unless they make money in streams and if
it's good and it gets streams they sign
it
[Music]
it's going to be brutal
black rappers are often better than
other races
wow
i think it's a racist point of view to
say that like that there that is often
better there are so many dope wrappers
that are black there are so many dope
wrappers that are not black like i don't
think the color of your skin determines
your penmanship skills so much of the
narratives that built and burst hip hop
is also what built in birth black
community and black folk if you're black
and you come from that and that's your
struggle and it's your story and it
connects with the history of being you
know um oppressed then you will always
have that advantage you know from the
from the viewer's standpoint you know
but i wouldn't say just because of like
you know being black makes you better i
like little nonsense
to not respect how he's marketed himself
and how he's bigged himself up you know
using the tools at his disposal but he's
just leveraged it in such a smart way
like i think that's so important to
remember that like hip hop was never
about like just are you the nicest with
a pen it was just like yo do you make
things that people enjoy no i agree with
everything being said you know as
another queer rapper who does a lot of
gender bending and stuff like that i
think little nasdaq's open up a lane for
other rappers alike that are can thrive
now because of that in the mainstream
memo had old town road blasting the car
when he was driving
having a couple
does of
make you a rapper
i mean i don't know like i didn't
consider myself a rapper until i started
making real money off that [ __ ]
i mean for me you're a rapper if you rap
you can have no songs out anywhere if
you rap you a rapper that's the way that
i see it then you're on the wrong side
yeah on the hill over here oh my fault
[Laughter]
if you just in your heart have been
resonant with hip-hop and you've been
writing your whole life and building
that just for yourself and you're a
rapper hey but not everybody on
soundcloud did that i agree you can have
just a couple of songs on soundcloud and
totally be a rap and ass rapper but you
could also have a couple of songs and
you put no time into them and then you
know it's not enough for me
i shouldn't have smoked i got caught in
mouth like a [ __ ]
yeah i can't even lie
really though you should have shared but
yeah yeah
it's okay to call women [ __ ] and
lyrics
three
two one
go
the reason i agree is because i think
you should be able to say whatever the
[ __ ] you want your lyrics you know what
i'm saying like if you're okay to stand
on what you say then stand on it and say
it you know yeah it shouldn't be
censored it's just like again you asked
the question do we think it's okay
they think it's okay the consequences if
you say something that's messed up talk
about it like if you got a white person
you know what i mean [ __ ] like right
you know then i got to deal with the
consequences you know what i mean
and that's all that you got to stand on
what you say you know i feel like the
culture we in it's like that's just like
the type of people you'll be around like
girls to be like yo you that [ __ ] like
drop that [ __ ] you know what i mean like
they'd be hyping each other up i don't
think it's ever like in such a
disrespectful way and like i guess it's
kind of like it's like a filler word
kind of it can't be but like hey we'll
be a better writer then you know don't
like don't don't realize you want me i
definitely don't rely on anything but
it's just like
you know i mean it helps get the point
across i'm just like but i think in a
larger scheme of things the majority of
times where i'm hearing the word [ __ ]
and rapping hip hop is the great degrade
women you know you just go line after
line and it's just like yo [ __ ] these
[ __ ] don't trust these hoes like it's
just like it's not like a yeah i'm
uplifting my [ __ ] it's like there's
not a lot of that but i do think it's
important or and i think it's important
as creatives of any genre to understand
that our music exists beyond ourselves
so our intention is not always going to
be received the way that we think it is
like i don't think any of us in here are
being like yo i hate women or like i'm
trying to be bad to women but i don't
know right but i think that that the
question is like what does okay mean
what it comes down to for me is like
just personally i'm not gonna put that
in my records i'm not gonna put that in
my music in my mind that's dope i mean
like you know word thank you you know
for anybody
whatever you want to do is dope in my
opinion for any artist if you want to
say some [ __ ] up i think we need crazy
people to say crazy [ __ ] sometimes like
you know [ __ ] uh dance with the devil
i said one of the first things okay so
yeah
we can all agree that that's the whole
that's one of the hardest songs of
hip-hop history right but i think we can
also all agree that what he's talking
about is not right but i think the
culture needs
it needs the ability to let people
express themselves so we have you know
like these big so or else it would be
too i don't know it'd be too bland it's
hard to rap about something other than
money sex or drugs
three
two one go
rap about what you want to rap about
like i think you're limited as an artist
if you're gonna say like those are the
only things that i'm out there and that
would be that would be stupid if you
want to rap about that that's fine too
that's the only reason i'm over here
because it's not hard
it's definitely not hard but i think
it's what people want to hear you know
it's like if you want to get in this
industry and make a successful living
off of it at a certain point you got to
say what the [ __ ] people want to hear
you know what i'm saying like everyone
wants money everybody want to have so
everybody does have sex a lot of people
do drugs in the or they've been impacted
by drugs so i think it's just inevitable
that it comes out a lot you know what i
mean but yeah i mean i just completely
disagree with the the question right
because i think like we've been talking
about little nauseas
old town road is just i don't even you
know it's just a western song and then
like i think there's so many lanes right
now that even if you're looking for
success memo like how did those people
how did those people come up though they
didn't come up talking about all that
spiritual woke [ __ ] j cole didn't come
out talking about that woke [ __ ]
actually jacob might have no jake jake
nicole might have yeah take home myself
you definitely did and success is also
such a spectrum of what the hell does
that [ __ ] mean success like the one
percent of artists that are making
millions of dollars per feature or also
completely eating and living and paying
all your bills that you need to right
and also got some money to vacate and
pay for the album but you know fans and
have fans and have a sustainable career
right and that way you absolutely can be
successful in having a niche market i
mean i'm doing it right now
hip-hop is misogynistic
three
two one go
oh man
there are a [ __ ] ton of misogynistic
artists misogynistic lyrics misogynistic
songs misogynistic practices i there's a
[ __ ] ton of work to be done in terms of
like what
that narrative and how we influence
people to
to think and not to think but i can't
say that the whole culture is misogyny i
mean we're all hip-hop all of us here
right i'm not a misogynist so i whenever
i hear like a question about hip-hop i
always think about what most deaf said
in 99 on black on both sides right he
said you know people ask me most how's
hip hop doing like it's a giant living
up in the mountain like it's some
creature and he's like hip-hop is the
people you know i do think that it's a
problematic question though because why
are you singling out hip-hop for that
you know i think the world is
misogynistic i think that country music
is misogynistic absolutely when do we
start making a choice as individuals to
look for that to seek out to not even
just be complicit in oh well that's just
how it is we also have to make that
extra effort to bring them around we as
gatekeepers our own communities we're
our own genres and our own you know
cities we have to be the ones to move
forward and until we do then i don't
know like i've always thought the whole
like stepping extra way to to go do
certain things like like me like going
to get a woman on my project because i
just want to get a woman on my project
it's disingenuous you know like if you
make hard [ __ ] there's always going to
be people that are going to [ __ ] with it
that's the bottom line i agree with it
and i disagree with it i agree with it
and that that's the hip hop i love you
know em said growing up it didn't matter
what color you was if you could spit
then you could spit that's it that's
what it was right and right now so much
of what people see from hip hop is
marketing the person who pops up at the
open mic and is super nice and the
people in the community respect it but
they never get that extra little push
but that's because that artist that
makes the decision to go to the open
mics is not pushing themselves to the
point to get to there yeah but it's not
an even playing field from the jump you
know
it's not though because systematically
women and queer folk and people of color
you know they are on different levels in
terms of resources even unconsciously
the same folks you know that are at the
open mic and how they're pushing
themselves how they're pushing
themselves each time they push
themselves
there are other people that kind of
validate them or allow them in higher
and higher up and they see this you know
this dopa white rapper and then they see
this like you know young women of color
rapper and then it's just like you're
like well this is what i'm more familiar
with this makes more sense to me so i'm
just going to go with it right people
are just don't make dollars don't make
sense to the industry my boy they don't
sign [ __ ] unless and make money in
streams and if it's good and it gets
streams they signing it trust me yeah i
mean sure if it makes money if it makes
me look like lonos x is gay he's
[ __ ] top of the world right now
yeah but that's one gay rapper in a
world of 100 straight rappers
or more thousands then get out there and
do it my boy
he can do it daddy straight up
i've always wanted to be a rapper three
two one go
i grew up in a neighborhood in a time
where it was the aftermath of the war on
drugs so i lost my father to gun
violence when i was four and you know he
was shot 22 times i lost a lot of
friends and relatives and then when i
heard 50 cent get richard.trying album
it was like he's telling my story i feel
you know he he carried me through a time
where there was a war going on in the
hood and i was like man i feel like i
want to do what he's doing and offer
that same hope to people in my community
and share my story you know so yeah i
knew once i was like 11 12 that i wanted
to rap you
know so the first time i ever wrote
rhymes i was five years old i i saw run
dmc as the musical guest on all that i
busted out my composition notebook and i
was like that was a sick song i got i
got to write all the lyrics i had the
beat in my head i wrote lyrics for my
own memory it was probably whack of [ __ ]
i was like five years old but i showed
it to my uncle the next day and i was
like yo check this out i wrote this like
run dmc remix and he was like this is
fire you gotta keep this up and i say
from that moment
that was like this is what i need to do
i need people to hear my lyrics i take
pride in my penmanship and i just want
everybody to appreciate the lyrics for
me i feel like it was after high school
but like i was freestyling high school
and stuff and like the homies was like
yo you kind of fired with the
freestyling but like i never took it
serious
and i was like nah school is not it at a
certain point i was like yeah rep music
as far as so i don't know i started
[ __ ] up in school towards the end i
wasn't feeling that [ __ ] you know and i
just [ __ ] uh started grinding with
the rap [ __ ] you know i never had no job
luckily i [ __ ] right away like my
first [ __ ] started taking off so i just
kind of like that's when i wanted to be
a rapper you know like is once i started
seeing like i dropped my first [ __ ]
song and she started going crazy and
then we just repeat and repeat and
repeat and that's when i want to be a
rapper but i definitely
not always wanted to be a rapper
actually rico pabon is a puerto rican
rapper from new york
very underground was the first time that
i saw like a contemporary latino rapper
that was doing something and i think
that's when i first started to think
that like oh i guess latinos you know
they kind of look like me can be in rap
so i grew up in delaware you know what
i'm saying like as a chinese kid in like
you know suburban delaware there weren't
a lot of
those kinds of voices from the margins
it was hip hop that was like giving me
that god book giving me those pathways
through facts so because of that i've
always wanted to be a rapper and like
krs once said right i am hip-hop
it's not something i do it's not
something that i try to do it's just who
i am and and that's where it comes from
for me
rap is damaging to young people
three
two
one
go
i think it can be because you can put
some like really young kids on to like
what was just talking about money sex
drugs and like
that's typically for older people i
would say like you know once you
graduate high school it's like more
common to be around that stuff but like
no i mean i think it can just like i
don't know it can be damaging you know i
mean like movies music video games like
to put blame on all that stuff for
influencing people like their actions i
don't know to to listen to something and
then act on it and then blame that for
what you did that's just a cop-out you
know so i would say because if a mind is
um not fully developed and they're
exposed to a certain kind of rap too
early then they can distort like their
perspective on things if the parent
isn't there to introduce it to them so
for my son i'm not gonna play you know
eminem album to him or whatever or a t
grizzly project now when he's older i'll
lay the foundational principles down
about okay here's life and here's what
this means and i always say your music
should evolve right so for me if i grew
up on a corner when i was 13 and now i'm
traveling to l.a doing the show i should
talk about that and i'll just say yeah
i'm still on the block robbing people
cause i'm lying you know what i mean
like people want to grow with their
artists and the people they look up to
like we see jay-z doing with 444 like
talking about manhood talking about
success and
acknowledging his mistakes and also you
know walking people through that process
that's important you know
all right it sounds so weird because i'm
going it's like going against my
argument about the [ __ ] thing but it's
really how i feel though like i don't i
don't [ __ ] with how so many people like
promoting all this drug use and [ __ ] and
pills you know what i'm saying one of my
brothers od'd like a [ __ ] month ago
you feel me if you're gonna talk about
it you also need to let [ __ ]
know especially if your audience is
younger people coming up i think you
should have a responsibility to say like
you know at least let them know what the
[ __ ] they're getting into you know if
i'm if i'm
not promoting that [ __ ] they're going to
go to someone who is you know if the
same way to say like tell i could tell
people as much as i want don't pop perks
don't do pills for the people who really
want to do that [ __ ] are going to go
they're not going to want to hear me you
know they're going to want to hear
people who are talking about that [ __ ]
so i guess
i don't think a [ __ ] just me saying
having a song can really make a
[ __ ]
change his life around you know like
obviously undervalue yourself gee i feel
like i mean think about yourself you're
in music because music also means
something to you right it's resonated
and built so much value when you built
yourself up like yeah maybe not one song
but it's an entry point it's a door that
opened up and you know to kind of tie
back into conversation i think even
beyond being artists and creators we
have responsibility as men as members of
the community right to be thoughtful
with our actions right consider it with
our words and then especially as
creators just to know that our [ __ ]
exists beyond us for the positive and
negative and to just take that in stride
and understand there's only consequence
from our actions good and bad
oh real oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
appreciation
[Music]
you